my name she's full day and this season
the school Bible is ramping up his
coverage of the NFL all in the name of
football but not fully and to kick it
off we are gone on our than acting
federal himself that's right the beast
mode is on I need you to be showing us
how to play listen I'm looking forward
to this one man a couple questions that
a lot of people watch the Super Bowl in
that yeah and I'm just wondering why do
you think lot of people watch the Super
Bowl but have no idea what's going on in
the game what is it that tracks that
part of it it's got to be the hard time
at the same really I'm not even gonna
front
you know I'm saying you are two more
missing she won't tell you who was in
the final but she'll tell you before
three you know I'm saying it's massive
like that but not to be better energy
you can feel the energy from the TV you
know super bonus so that's what I think
that's what draws people with is
Christian Tissier all final you think
you think there's like space in our game
yeah for like some aspects of the other
film and what would it be if you was to
take send I think my off-time if they
cut flannel Chaney maybe Drake come out
I'm just saying exactly FA look into
[Laughter]
someone and use use mistaken for NFL
yeah I love story I've said this before
but pulled over by the police I'm stayin
on wrong
just laying y'all know I was minding my
business they pulled me over R so what I
did that's when I played football there
was an old one back in America so no
football NFL I played football dasi he
pulled me over any telling you are do
trust me at the player happened now I
think a few more people did you say my
favorite player is no you know I was
looking to try to get to unless my soul
which is about nice my guy at the moment
I saw every day oh no you find that gang
sighs I sure do you think yeah you'd be
able to take up and if you're running
back see I don't like to come across
arrogant but I think I would shut our
running back I'm waving in the light
yeah you know it's like I'm putting you
down gonna see
that's happy you know so we have to put
that to the test we absolutely would be
definitely well as we know the Super
Bowl was the gate was with the Denver
Broncos versus the Carolina Panthers
yeah and they actually have their first
game kicking off on Friday
yeah the opening game no yeah yeah it's
fine it's Thursday night yeah 1:30 a.m.
sky watch it I'm gonna be watching it
make sure you watch it because I'm
telling it to be a real good season all
day every day and oh yeah before we kick
off some games we're giving you a copy
to the opportunity to win a copy of
Madden 17 for ps4 and on the Xbox you've
got the over 18 but what you've got to
do is you gotta let us know in the
comments below who's gonna win this game
and me obviously and the record Finn
come on now listen if you wanna win the
game if you wanna win the game
pick me let's see yeah tell me you know
you know you know - are you alright you
ready for this are you think I'm about a
bin ready okay cool Denver hey listen
the PAP is gonna be dabbing on your
tireless call between you go yeah yes
solid solid services
[Applause]
it gets real when it gets up either by
blending assignment yet and you know you
know it's real rough you know it's real
listen my man are coming for you now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
therefore this shotgun parts yet no it's
looses notice you so it's gonna be a
straight up straight I touch down we got
no defense
oh I just say what hold on hold on
yeah yeah Danny won't eat no one it you
don't want it just slow it down with
yellow key
yeah intersection even Schwartz watch
what Emily busted okay okay okay so
which of the london games you looking
for I mean you look before what does if
you've got games at wicket in yeah you
got some game we've got game it took a
couple games at Wembley yes sir what's
your what would you be looking to touch
me for you to reach what you know what
it'll ask me the tricky thing game
because that's what the chance is gonna
be a tear so I'm looking forward to when
the Giants come down cool so I'm looking
forward to the with the Giants come over
chicken and so looking forward to my
first game so oh yeah yeah so the more
and more people know that I'm starting
to get more involved and excited about
NF know so I'm looking forward to my
first game
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I do want to set this up at the
top you know I'm an NFL because I want
to try one out of a two-day training
session two days right
[Music]
[Laughter]
Hey go for it
but then my dear I said I bring him in
on Sunday I bring all of you in at that
time I'm not screaming let me see this
oh we had that madman just watch oh he
just didn't know it you're gonna have to
kick it
it's bad this bad boy is coming back and
telling us if you see the students faces
it's time for a touchdown
[Applause]
on a Sunday listen time MVP yeah you
know you know you know that in the game
yet people like talk smack in the game
yeah I mean like yeah same way to do in
real life and a hell yeah but how can we
don't see that if it was it's not like
this another reason like NFL because
it's very much
catch that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about straight
to the 50-yard line
Oh straight to the 50-yard line my
Palace is armed listen you know these
over the W in front of me I'm all about
expressing yourself and lose yourself in
a ballroom you know we the football
athlete they didn't smack - all right
kid says no I was more I was more when I
was younger you know
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
my defense is a job ok ok ok ok
[Applause]
man we've like would like you know like
this laws at FIFA gamers in the senior
you think you think man is a place you
can step in and dominate before anyone I
mean these grabs a
[Applause]
and monopolize the whole garden scene
well I'm coming up doing my thing and
coming up there I'm coming home without
a mat and 17 gonna be showing it
[Applause]
so I'd like to think that my attacking
skew you kick in a minute but hey yeah I
mean you're not in the running game yeah
[Applause]
running game we don't one
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like if what Broncos here we're
like a Premier League side you didn't
let me do you do compared to like or to
is the mine
[Applause]
yeah would you say you
[Applause]
okay welcome to Mary's coming on
interception
come on defense when you've been on Jack
[Applause]
and if we like I'm leaving my NFL
managers like differ from that
[Music]
you know what I don't think they did for
that much because one thing I'll give
Premiership managers now than football
managers you know they're passionate can
you shoot them on the sideline and
they'll be
[Applause]
it's nothing tithi exactly huh no that's
Italy that's what it is that's in first
teacher Nick
no I'm saying us once a thousand years
in slowly and tell you can maybe just
wanted that I'm just I'm just making
exam is coming it's coming balloon
believe me Marcia Marcia
[Applause]
man Donny fingers is a lot of is a lot
of players so for you know they'll have
a general manager there's a lot of
players to to handle so I give the props
22:24 get up do it da young man that
today's do it
it's a bit in between the mines that's
like a number 10 I said what I do we job
for now I always pray about the format
well yeah because obviously what you say
they but like in the NFL in but like a
defense called a defensive back there
okay I'm saying this is where this is
where you don't mean rolled up bench
presses
Oh
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey hey listen where's the rest where
are the rest
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
would tell you 2,000 yards and college
all-round all-american American ready go
run boys it guys do not today
this is my house give me the house no
you ain't cause I was at the end job you
just give it a take your weight swing
call this is the game mrs. games in here
can you throw these yeah
[Applause]
now this game I found that say now hi
listen we enter a game closer to the
last for you any law school or tactics
satellite I would bring into that you
bring in now yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
make it that version you gonna go see
what's knocking at the door this is what
we do we make it we make it yeah school
[Applause]
[Applause]
in the store back to you
second class we're gonna get a heavy pot
that's it listen if you ain't pictures
idea now's the time you pick me because
now I'm fun you get real it's about to
get real I've seen it to get real no I'm
saying this is the pin speed V there's
another piece all the way to giving it
to that I'm hunting a Ricky so I'm
saying it's real hard
Matt Matt I've got a few minutes ours
you've got a minute and gravy she
tonight in the wake up days the way they
set this up back way to set up is the
achieving you've coming to their lay up
[Applause]
[Music]
yes yes touchdown right by now my
defenses on beast mode is fully on it oh
oh don't be giving you this
[Applause]
yes
what will play what will pay for a few
seconds up to 5 seconds of shop I see
people right now as you complete
attention to me is beauty everybody's
nervous 15 seconds come on
yeah hey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this has been amazing keep it locked to
NFL and the swap Bibles are going to
bring you the stuff all throughout the
season make sure you check out the
raccoon friend wanna check out chicken
squawk we love it